alrighty I'm more Sicilian let's try
King's pawn plate if you play e5 in
response to e4 you really you really
better know it's what's going on let's
try the philidor whoa I just had all
this corner of my eye on the chat car
hers you've been here since you've been
a friend since the myspace days that's
crazy chest network on myspace that is
going back sometime if that's what you
meant Wow when the night didn't used to
be how it is now okay 97
why did I do it like this
why'd I move my bishop I'll like that
um let's do this okay i was actually
fearful of bishop here with some sacks
on this square but that's not the case
now so with that structural change I
want to get an f5 and what white should
be looking to do is what what's the pond
break white should be getting in
c5 that's a long way off rookie wat
rookie eight if you didn't realize I'm
doing that so I could go for my little
dance here with my night ideally I'd
like to have the dark square Bishop Soph
the board and then jump my knight in
whoa I shouldn't have done that and then
jump my night into that square that was
almost a really bad pre-move okay well
should I be welcoming exchanges am I
welcome to an exchange yes and no that's
it actually tough call right there my
Brooke would much rather be on fa dat
this point I my opponent has a space
advantage so if I do this we're
welcoming more exchanges but at the same
time it would be the exchange of good
versus bad bishops so I really don't
know one way or the other which one was
best to just block right away or what
I'd like to do what next get my night to
this square so let's do that both are
now converging on that square and if
it's taken away from me then I have
Bishop h3 in mind okay now this comes
with tempo is there anything better
probably not in which piece should I be
going with I'm going to go with the one
that's more tactically vulnerable okay
now i have the bishop pair my queen is
my night is hitting the queen and it
seems like there's going to be some
issues on this square Bishop out to g4 I
could take the other bishop and have two
bishops versus two nights it's probably
a good idea to but
what about g6 f5 and maybe f4 and then
get in g4 I like my night a real lot
Bishop g4 is also worth considering go
with that it's gotta react you can't
allow me to just take and smash smash up
that structure okay now i could take
here undo this what up what a bug
let's get this in open up the F file
forget about this slower idea of getting
in g6 I don't need help to get into five
what I was ok hang on okay now i think
i'd take here and then rook takes here
and I get there's there's an issue now
with this fortunately I have in response
to Queenie for I have rook f4 otherwise
maybe that could have been a bit awkward
so now there's some structural damage I
want to really just pile up on this
night basically I'm going to end up
piling up on a pond that's on f3 double
def ponds this night will have a nice
home on that square ok counter-attack
the Queen backs up here that's probably
not good here if anything also stays out
of the way of maybe pawn push with tempo
Queen to e3 is probably best a minute
advantage all right let me take this and
actually Bishop here is probably a good
idea he's not doing anything from this
Square and now there's possibilities for
even rook age for this can't be correct
can it rook check pawn takes Bishop
takes that actually could be a very
difficult one to win rook check pawn
takes Bishop takes Queen pawn takes this
night how do I get rid of it I actually
want to keep my bishop around I much
rather have my queen come out to h4 my
Brooke come out to this square I think
this is a much better option again I
could have won the Queen there but maybe
there was some okay the computer
planning the black side will be able to
break down anything i'm pretty sure but
i just i think that this is maybe a
better practical try just stop the
threats that white has this is still
this is not going anywhere now
anyway scoop my clean up if I played to
this square there's no there would have
been that because I had that stuff my
pun is playing very fast very fast I
think my last plan is going to be what
let's do this I want to get out of there
i think if you back my bishop up that
night moves maybe then I smashed through
on this square man okay let's stop this
pawn advance if night here I just drop
all the way back to d8 to watch over
this pond if this one's ever threatened
I just push it forward I have all my
beat my base point would be protected
age forward drop all the way back my
opponents putting up a lot of resistance
this is a tough structure to work with
but it's a so far so good with a holding
it together 94 maybe I could even
consider that alright just meet that
threat there's also counter attacking
moves but this is right where my rip
belongs okay now that's dropping my
Brooke is defending this that was
probably just missed probably just
missed so now I could even transfer my
attention to picking off this pond or
even just give up the two rooks and get
the Queen and then my queen becomes very
active but now it's going to be big
trouble very very big trouble on f to
hit one more time and it's very
difficult to defend night to e4 I just
pile up on it Bishop each for that
square was covered
I think that's going to be resigned time
resigned time no okay let's keep this
really really simple come back here and
right here after 90 for my queen okay
right here my queen wants to be on h3
this Bishop is boxing out the night
watching out for any checks the night is
not able to do anything more than just
sit there any foreign it's not a support
point the queen is having to watch over
it more activity for my queen I feel
like I should be able to maybe sack on
this square and then play here at some
point I don't know anything really hung
up a rope can actually trade down if I
really wanted to not going to do that no
time anyhow but I was thinking about
Queen right here to this square no time
good resistance in that one with a bad
having to work with that bad structure I
would really consider I don't know if
these opening moves or a good idea it's
rare that I even play the philidor and I
don't think I played it well at all
because of my opening decisions with the
bishop like what do you do what do i do
if you play Bishop c4 if I play Knight
f6 you take the pawn king takes Knight
check the night jumps in here the night
jumps here I just stir some problems so
after Bishop c4 I don't think I could be
playing that f6 so do i play h6 then I
might be having you do h6 I really fan
of doing that but anyhow just something
to be aware of go with the very typical
if you Bishop c4 if you're playing the
black side you just go with the routine
development watch out Bishop snip night
g5 to e6 this night is masking the
bishops view of e6 that's a problem
but since things are closed up this
night would much rather actually not
even be developed I don't think just so
that you could get in to see five
advanced that's really the direction
white should be going in but that was
the direction that you know like white
never went in that direction and it was
just all black on the Kings side this is
the area that I wanted to be at or be
playing on and now it's just a serious
problem so you have to know how to
follow up if you're going to close the
center in short like this with the d5
well you have to you're going to have to
get in c5 are you going to be able to
get that in that's the big question to
really be asking yourself and you really
weren't able to do that so that turned
out to be a big problem especially
actually as soon as I got a night on f4
you're really really fighting an uphill
battle at that point this I just know
like just from playing the computer a
real lot I mean I've been doing that
more recently but I mean even before
that I know just from my experience
playing its computer there's certain
positions you just have a feeling
something really really bad is going to
happen and just staring at this night
right here on f4 that right there tells
me something really really bad is about
to happen and he's not easily kicked
away g3 just compromises the white
position h3 in particular okay alrighty
let me close